it's always been known that Charlie
Watts was a great player and you have
even said I needed Charlie Watts and as
a non- musician I go really why did
Keith need Charlie Watts but then I
realized he gave you something he had
feel he had intelligence rock and roll
doesn't necessarily need the whole
battery of drums you know it's got to do
with when to not hit you
know where what do you got if you if
you're making music silence is your
canvas let's play this for a second this
is from the new album Live By The Sword
listen to
this you had the track you had bill on
it and you had Charlie on
it you look like you're getting sad
listening to it are you tell me well
it's the last time that bunch is ever
going to be heard together you know
it's hard to accept yeah yeah it is you
know I mean hey I miss Charlie every day
man you know there's a photo as I come
out of my bedroom there's the first
thing I see is I have a portrait of
Charlie on the staircase kind of no
kidding always give him a salute on the
way you know wow yeah Charlie wats was a
solid guy I me in the beginning when all
you guys had no money and you had to
hire Charlie to be your drummer cuz he
was already working professional
gig were you like what we got this guy
we have Noy you know what I mean but if
we didn't have him we wouldn't be able
to do the gig you know and and the gigs
paid off right away and Charlie wanted
to do it that's what we knew is that
even though he was trying to be
professional so well I do need you know
to get my drums from a to be uh certain
amount of cash you know and but after a
couple of gigs uh we knew we had him
anyway you had him yeah did we luck out
with that guy man you know and in the
studio is where he shined too right
because absolutely because not only
could he hold the beat but he could come
up with something original yeah there
was a a feeling about CH a subtlety
about how he played he would throw in
ideas that you hadn't really thought of
oh a little Calypso here a little you
know um sambers and uh at the same time
such a solid beat and so I never had to
worry about thing which gives you know
the rest of the freedom to like fly you
know because you're never wondering if
the beat's going to hold oh it's
unbelievable